they represent the diversity of our
economy and what the same help the
government is offering to companies and
employees whilst others have had their
wages protected the self-employed
workforce who've had their lives
disrupted by the coronavirus have had to
fend for themselves driving instructor
david has gone from back-to-back
bookings to zero and he's not sure when
he'll next be on the road
there's worry where's the money gonna
come from what's going to happen
frustration that more for my pupils who
were moving along quite nicely and then
will sudden they've got to come to a
stop we're okay for a couple of weeks so
to speak but thereafter there's no money
coming in I've got to live off what I
put aside in order to make sure that
food remains on the table later
Chancellor Rishi sunic is expected to
announce a package of measures to
support millions of self-employed
workers the prime minister says drawing
up plans hasn't been easy it's been more
complex as you can understand to support
the self-employed because that they have
there are many different arrangements
that they have and it's been it's been
tricky to work out a package that will
address the needs of as many people as
possible but that is being done has been
done at incredible speed one way of
getting through it is with simple
antibody tests to determine who has had
the virus the government's confirmed
it's bought over 3 million but they're
wary of rushing them out to homes until
they're confident of their accuracy
because I'm a GP as soon as I got my
symptoms I was concerned that I'd was at
risk clearly of infecting others and at
the time there were still testing pods
which were run by one one one and even
though I wasn't from a high-risk area I
knew I was so I got tested now it was
very important for me to get tested
because I'm a health professional I put
patients at risk if it was the case that
I could have been tested at home that I
could have been done on a pinprick but
somebody could have got the tests for me
it would really been a game changer
pressure mounts on hospitals too and
their capacity to cope with a growing
number of patients needing treatment for
Kovach 90-year we expect the demand for
critical care beds to continue to rise
over the lenten the next two weeks this
is going
to be a close-run thing we all know that
and anybody who looks around the world
can see this is going to be difficult
for every Health System the road ahead
will be trying but more than half a
million people have volunteered to help
the NHS in this fight the altruism of
Britain shining even in darkness ash
Najarian at Sky News